hi i'm pamela champshire from commune
and this is my friend and client and
partner at ace hotel kelly soden is
going to do this
talk with me we've done
several hotels together
and
we've figured out some rules about
collaborating so we're going to go over
our golden rules of collaboration the
first golden rule that ace and commune
have come up with over the years good
intentions bring great results so with
the director from ace to keep things
local and give back to los angeles and
make the project about los angeles and
commune embarked on setting up a
narrative our narrative was really
simple it was what if mary pickford who
had built this building in 1927 had a
wild affair with rudolf schindler who
was a modernist and
a contemporary of hers at that time and
they had a daughter named exin cervenka
who was from the band x so this
represented a lot of different aspects
of the design for us obviously mary
pickford built this incredible spanish
colonial gothic building with a 1600
seat theater that you can see on the
edge there
and so she represented flappers in that
era of hedonism and freedom in los
angeles
and rudolph really you know these
buildings are actually cement and it's
actually a cement bunker and very spare
inside and there wasn't much history on
the interior of the building when we got
it so he represented sort of this whole
minimalism and um other uh you know the
other counterpoint of los angeles in the
20s the last bit of the the love child
the la punks from the 70s and 80s really
for us represented ace and the no-hold
bars you know irreverent
outsider culture that ace has embodied
this is the lobby
this is the restaurant space the
downstairs
this is the mezzanine of the restaurant
this is one of the hotel rooms
a typical bathroom
and this is the rooftop bar so with a
clear intention set everyone had a
narrative that they worked into
i think we had 30 to 50 artists and
artisans working on this project as well
as hundreds of people on the job site
and this is the theater space which
underwent a two-year restoration which
has now
become very pivotal to downtown
so our second golden rule is allow time
and space for dreaming and exploration i
think it's
important for both ace and commune that
the artists are actually part of the
conceptual process the artists were all
brought in as early as these stages some
of them found materials salvaged parts
and found inspiration from particular
floors it's important to make sure
they're involved this early on so that
it doesn't become decoration but that is
actually a seamless part of the fabric
of the project this is what became later
the rooftop bar
okay defining parameters from the get-go
i think if you're going to engage an
artist or artist and you need to really
be very upfront about the parameters
that they're working within if it's as
small as a detail in the room like this
hook i think we need to really define
function we made everything in these
rooms from the toilet paper holders to
the towel holders to the desk caddies
and we make sure that the parameters are
respected so it's important that every
artist is allowed to go through their
process one of the artists that we
worked with mike mills we commissioned
him to do all the in-room art and we
wanted to take a different approach than
we have in some of our hotels in the
past and so with mike he was really
inspired by
1927 the year the building was built so
he
dove into the history of los angeles in
1927 spent about two years researching
reading every book he could get his
hands on every documentary
and came up with a list of you know
hundreds and hundreds of different
interesting facts uh for what happened
during that time on the other end of
things we had the haas brothers simon
and nikki engaged in doing several
pieces at the hotel this is the
reception desk and they had a completely
mysterious and different kind of process
which involved their friends and their
family and at the very last second they
were like oh we got to make this
quintessentially la so they came up with
foggy palm trees which i think was
brilliant there's 16 oil panels of these
foggy palm trees that dot la so they had
a completely different process from mike
and we had to honor both of them so
somebody's got to do the dirty work and
make things happen so you know on a
hotel project there are a lot of
different consultants and people that
are involved just to get things
permitted to get things designed
produced this is an example of the light
fixture by michael schmidt he's a
costume and jewelry designer who's done
a lot of stuff with cher madonna and
lady gaga we brought him in early and as
we were decommissioning some of the
lights in the 1600 person seated theater
that we had he decided to salvage some
of those lights and he spent about two
years collecting chains up and down the
coast of california
and put together this chandelier so to
speak
and it required us to work with
structural engineers the lighting
designers a number of different
consultants that really had to buy into
this art piece
and not work against us and tell us it
was you know too heavy and impossible to
do
allow for a margin for air
so these are actually some collages so
we had these sort of two eras of
hedonism and freedom in los angeles book
ended which is the flappers in the 20s
at one end and the l.a punks in the 70s
and 80s at the other end so um some of
the kids at commune made these collages
in the meeting areas you know we wanted
something that expressed the freedom and
hedonism of these two periods in los
angeles and there's rubber cement and
there's it's not cut very perfectly and
you know there's crazy layers but you
can feel how much went into these
collages
no one should ever work for free ever
so we had two
artists who approached us about doing
altars in the theater space at ace and
we have learned throughout the years to
always pay an artist and always make
sure that not only their materials are
covered but that they get a fee this
piece is done by kevin willis he had
never shown his ceramics to anyone and
we went crazy when we went to his studio
he ended up doing a lot of the voters on
the roof and the restaurant and once we
settled on a materials fee he made these
90 cats and a self-portrait of himself
as our lady of fingers
and
if you go to the theater you can see it
right on the left as you walk in
on the other end of the spectrum was
nikki and simon's mother who's an
ex-opera singer and her name is emily
tracy and we were thrilled when she
offered to do an altar she takes old
statues and reworks them and came in and
did this beautiful piece which is in the
downstairs women's bathroom lobby
check your ego at the door this is a big
one and this applies not only to us as
designers but also the artists that
we're working with this is alma allen
who commune has worked with for almost
10 years now he's always been a part of
every project we've done he's really an
artist and not a furniture maker and we
treat him as such we settled on
pencilwood for these pieces and we gave
him heights and he went to town
no agents or lawyers in the studio
this is another big one that should have
been earlier
simon and nikki we would have never
gotten them going through their agents
it would have never worked out for this
project so we went right to them they
did all these graphite pencil drawings
in the lobby and in the restaurant that
are sort of a pictorial and cultural
essay on los angeles so it's everything
from the hollywood hills
to diane keaton we have tom bradley
represented but had there been lawyers
or agents involved we would have never
been able to use these likenesses and
this would have never happened
so bad timing is the killer i think we
were really fortunate uh with this
project specifically the theater had
been owned by
reverend dr gene scott he had basically
run his congregation out of this theater
and so this really beautiful ornate 1927
historic theater was preserved so when
we started working with commune on the
project they came in and preserved a lot
of the things that were in the theater i
think we all knew to fight for extra
time for the theater to happen
a lot of it was about deleting design
elements so that you could see the
ordinateness of all the cast plaster
and giving proper time to lighting
cleaning you know all the restoration
work that had to happen i think all in
all kelly and i were so fortunate to
have companies that are not about
authorship or one voice or one star but
about many voices layered together to
tell a story and make and create an
experience and we feel very fortunate to
be in the design business at this time
thank you